but in Tampa Bay where they got the
quarterback they wanted the guy who was
number one on their list Tom Brady
they're bringing back a guy who was the
second overall pick in the 2010 draft it
was last May late May right around
Memorial Day weekend anatomic ensues
signed with the Buccaneers the first
time around after the Buccaneers dumped
Gerald McCoy this time Chris reportedly
bringing him back on a one-year eight
million dollar deal he is staying put
along with Shaq Barrett and Jason
pierre-paul we know how Bruce Arians
feels about that defense and how it can
continue to improve which will make it a
lot easier for the offense but your
thoughts on Suh sticking around in Tampa
Bay for one more year
well I just can't help but to think
about this front seven in Tampa and you
know first off and that's what I think
appealed probably to Tom Brady and and
of course the big thing is but you got
it let me just listen listen to the
names alone vitae via right by de Vega
am I saying that right yes vitae Vega
might if he is that idea yes vitae via
is a game wrecker to be he is going to
become a household name this year then
you got a dhama consume and then you
said Shaquille Barrett and then it's jpp
on the other side of defense at and it's
Levante David and Devon white at middle
linebacker I mean when you talk about
that group right there because most
games are played in nickel personnel
where there's only two linebackers in
the field that is impressive and to me
the thing that jumps out more than
anything was the number one run defense
in football but I think this is things
where you got to make sure this defense
is good especially early on in the
season and we'll see what the schedule
looks like
but a good defense is gonna help Tom
Brady in that offense come around if
things come off to a little bit of a
slow start they're not gonna have the
pressure of you know oh man we gotta go
out there and score 28 points in week
one or we can't win a football game no
you would hope that the Buccaneers
defense approves this year and they
could play a style of football at least
early on to where Tom Brady doesn't have
to carry the team in a new organization
and a new system and getting used to all
these new things and it gives them a
little bit of a wiggle room as far as
that's concerned where do we think Suh
is right now though 10 years removed
from when he was drafted by the Lions he
had the big money contract with the
Miami Dolphins
funds they got to the point where they
decided they weren't getting the return
on the investment they made he ended up
with the Rams the Rams were frustrated
about his pass rush skills when they put
him on the outside that's what prompted
them to trade for Dante Fowler jr.
during the 2018 season Rams didn't try
to resize him he lands with Tampa Bay
what did you see from him last year what
does he have left in comparison to the
best that we used to see of in dhama can
sue yeah well those days are gone I mean
and Amin consumed was one of those guys
Mike that we would have put in like you
know the upper tier of the play up and
his prime of his career you know and
then special in his prime ministry R not
only cuz he can be disruptive but also
had the size and strength to hold double
teams and you couldn't move him inside
so he's almost a run stopper combined
with the disrupter at the same time
that's why he was the second pick of the
draft he was special that way now this
day and age no you don't see a ton of
disruption that's the one thing I say
you you're seeing to escape out of his
game but still has incredible strength
never really lose his battles Mike I
mean that's the one thing when I look at
Sioux on film or watch him you know I'm
big into when you lose a battle with a
guard or a double team what's it look
like
and his losses are stalemates where he
just doesn't get moved and he stays
there now
you know back in the old days he might
have broke through the double-team and
made a tackle or whatever now he can
hold his ground and still there's value
in that so he's a really good player and
when he wants to turn it on and it's a
big situation you know he has that
veteran ability to kind of raise it up a
notch like we saw with the Rams in the
playoffs a few years ago and that's
right and you know what I had forgotten
about that that when he was in the chase
for his first championship ring we saw a
higher level of performance from advice
ensued than we had during the regular
season and you know here comes Tom Brady
and we've talked about how he's going to
affect a locker room how he's going to
affect a culture he's been around 20
years he's seen guys get their buttons
pressed he's going to come up with ways
to press the buttons of in dhama can sue
to get more out of sue from week one to
week 16 not just wildcard round
divisional round championship round
Superbowl if they get that far and it's
and he's gonna be doing it on it's just
it's gonna be natural it's part of the
natural competition that oozes for Tom
Brady every day and that is one of the
things that I think is gonna coax more
out of and AMA consume he's never been
around a quarterback like this no Mike
it's a great point and it's something
that you know in my time in New England
that really jumped out to me now I
didn't get to be on the practice field a
whole lot when I was working up there I
was usually stuck in my dungeon breaking
down film but when I did go out brady
has a great way raising the competition
level in practice you know first off he
loves football and brady is that kind of
guy then I'll talk some crap and oh yeah
you like that laser I'm throwing lasers
today and it'll run it'll bring up the
whole football team as far as their
intensity for practices and as you know
when you practice better you usually end
up playing better when you put day after
day after day together and that is the
beauty of what Brady's going to do
nobody on that team has seen anything
like Tom Brady right now and I think
they're all gonna look at it and go man
I might have been slacking my whole
career and compared to this guy I need
to raise my game don't wonder he's one
of the greatest of all time
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports